Wow sure oh sorry I'm so sorry
it doesn't matter it's totally fine yeah
I can get you a new one I honestly don't
even want this it's just straight but
okay so you were doing any favors right
then yeah
hello this good to meet you see ya
French in the morning eleven o'clock is
dead yeah no that'd be great oh you
wanna go to the den yeah hash browns
do they very often but I really got a
piece we could go out of here whoa hey
what are you but even we always go in
the other it saves time I gotta change a
tampon and like you know that scene from
the shining with the elevator and the
blood and just like you wouldn't want to
go in there with me it's gonna be nasty
but you don't get your period for
another 13 days okay so I'm gonna go in
alone and you just like stay out here
all right
you guys can't with it man check all the
chicks here tonight Batman too bad
you've already [ __ ] all of them crazy
lion tomorrow no Nicole likes wave oh no
damn it
someone took my whiskey this uh
salespeople this way let me guess
you are pretending to text people when
you're really just refreshing your
Instagram about 10,000 times is it that
transparent yeah I've been there
I feel like I'm the only sober person at
this party you're definitely the only
sober person start oh my god I'm June by
the way yeah I'm a work-study program
right at the library yeah yeah me and
every single English major guilty I mean
schools need teachers right there you
are what are you doing what are you
drinking this is not a Madison here and
she sounded like she was an English
major and I think it's so cool hey hey
remember that time you said that English
majors were pointless I never said that
I think that the spoken word and word in
general are just very beautiful
beautiful things
okay excuse us one second it says dude
what about
he's too smart yeah something like that
what about her yeah
he's hot well see you tomorrow
hey hey aren't you a plumber come on
let's dance
okay you can't keep doing that I'm
actually gonna go talk to you Madison
oh I can I can go through to talk to her
sesame College is a time for you to
explore yourself you know just really
develop friendships that you know would
last a lifetime
you mean so much to me maybe we should
take this opportunity to you know branch
out a little bit wait what are you
saying
I wants the other people Oh outside of
our dorm
I want to make other friends is what I
mean yeah sure whatever okay you're mad
no no it's fine I
I have to go mingle I gotta go you know
you have a nicest person I've met all
night yeah guys in England aren't nice I
mean okay
they say we get out of here don't know
come on drinking sorry you said drinking
Oh a little bit yeah here do you want
some I'll get you another time you don't
mind
okay tomorrow and leave already
what let's play sometimes I'm busy
leave I wanted yeah someone stole my
whisky there's no more pizza left and I
was hit by a proximal 14 beer pong balls
Wow yeah and now my ex-boyfriend is here
flirting with the girl I always knew he
had a crush on
so female intuition is never wrong no
right I feel like I should just go talk
to him
not a minute no yeah you're right
you know what every once I'm gonna leave
before I do something I regret
yeah I mean you could come with me if
you want you know we could get high an
arch both yeah yeah absolutely yeah
let's please see that's hey sorry about
that
okay yeah he seems so nice at birth is
not nice we don't want to hang out with
him anyway
really and knocked anything over them I
don't know maybe I shouldn't yeah I
think everything going can I walk you
out
yeah I got you know to do what he did no
no this point just want to get away of
something actually okay
so I thought today was I thought no I'm
just gonna use the calculator real quick